[Music]
foreign
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month it was a year of Milestones just
ask Jim Carrey who was the first actor
to hit the 20 million dollar salary Mark
for cable guy plus it was a year for
very quotable movies what with
characters like happy Cruella Sherman
Sydney and President Whitmore so go
Frost your tips put on your hypercolor
T-shirt and starter jacket and let's
head back to 1996.
[Music]
there is no way that you could have been
as bad at hockey as you are at golf all
right let's go
I don't want a PCU I want the whole
thing oh
[Music]
and stirring up one emotion in
particular when it arrived in February
was the Adam Sandler golf comedy Happy
Gilmore about a wannabe hockey player
who finds unexpected success as a
professional golfer even though Sandler
has given us a few gems lately pun
intended this movie actually remains one
of a handful of fresh films over his
entire career especially when it comes
to comedies and if there's one secret to
that success well it's all in the hips
talked about
how green
hey it's all that come on work with me
now it's all in his yeah
Happy Gilmore may be just one in a long
line of Fish Out of Water comedies that
Define the early part of Sandler's big
screen career but the film arguably
changed the face of sports movies or at
the very least the sport of golf and has
attracted a legion of fans unlike any of
his other comedies the unforgettable
lines and oft imitated golf swing plus
the introduction of Bob Barker to a new
generation has kept this film as
relevant as ever critics say those who
enjoy Adam Sandler's schtick will find
plenty to Love in This gleefully
juvenile take on professional golf those
who don't however will find it unfunny
and forgettable
[Music]
of course you can pass as an uncle
you're a great performer I'm a great
director together we can do almost
anything oh a man really absolutely oh
we've got five hours
all right first get your pinky down it's
up again
all right oh my God
Taking Flight in March of 96 was the
comedy The Birdcage which is a remake of
a classic French play and film from the
70s called Le Kaja full in this version
Robin Williams stars as a gay Miami club
owner who pretends to be straight and
hide his relationship with his life
partner played by Nathan Lane in order
to appease his son's future
father-in-law a controversial Republican
senator played by Gene Hackman of course
given the level of performance talent
that was involved director Mike Nichols
would film one good take sticking to the
script and then let guys like Robin
Williams Nathan Lane and Hank Azaria do
their thing
I don't want to see me I'm hideous
I can't go door
[Music]
the certified fresh film was a hit with
fans and critics topping the box office
for four straight weeks on its way to
reaching 185 million dollars worldwide
and among the accolades The Birdcage
picked up a Screen Actors Guild award
for outstanding ensemble cast for
obvious reasons critics say Mike Nichols
wrangles agreeably amusing performances
from Robin Williams and Nathan Lane in
this fun if not quite essential remake
of the French comedy La Casio fall
Julia I know you're upset you you just
gotta breathe we both just you gotta
breathe
cow I gotta go Julia we got cows
this one was directed by John debonte of
speed Fame and written by author Michael
Crichton along with his wife actress
turned writer and Marie Martin Helen
Hunt and Bill Paxton Star as estranged
husband and wife Storm Chasers who team
up to test a new device he invented
before their biggest rival played by
Carrie elways steals their Thunder
Steven Spielberg who served as an
executive producer was once attached to
direct but backed out and James Cameron
and Robert zemeckis were also considered
before John dubont left Godzilla for the
job
[Music]
right on us
no no no twister gross nearly 500
million dollars at the worldwide box
office and became the second highest
grossing film of 1996 after Independence
Day it also received Oscar Noms for best
visual effects and best sound but lost
to Independence Day and The English
Patient respectively and the film is
actually quite notable for being one of
the very first films ever released on
DVD in the United States date night
critics say a high concept Blockbuster
that emphasizes special effects over
three-dimensional characters Twisters
visceral Thrills are often offset by the
film's generic plot you know a few hours
ago my biggest problem was judging a
stuffing contest
now look at me
stuck in a jail cell
with some angry 400 pound man whose life
you wreck
you clipped them didn't you
I'm sorry Uncle Phil
ah it's the worst Thanksgiving I ever
had and thank you so much for sharing it
with me but
should I say rap on things in May of 96
was The Fresh Prince of Bel Air leaving
the airwaves after six seasons and 148
episodes the NBC sitcom starred Will
Smith as kind of himself in a role that
he apparently auditioned for on the spot
in front of NBC Chief Brandon tartikoff
while at a party at the home of Quincy
Jones and the pilot was filmed three
months later hashtag Hollywood the
series was created by Andy and Susan
barowitz who previously worked on shows
like family ties and The Facts of Life
what y'all do with our clothes it's
under him
Bel Air's not that long of a walk
we will get our clothes and then we're
gonna go no no no from the looks of this
brother he's a very heavy sleeper
and over its six-year run the Fresh
Prince featured dozens of celebrity
cameos like Bo Jackson Oprah Quincy
Jones Chris Rock and William Shatner a
reunion special and retrospective which
reunited the original living cast
members debuted on HBO Max in November
of 2020. critics say now this is the
story of how Will Smith's career got
flipped turned upside down from Top 40
rapper with bankable flair to a
Transcendent star in The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air
enough is enough you have bribed cajoled
and killed and you have done it using
loyalties on the inside you want to
shake hands with the devil that's fine
with me I just want to make sure that
you do it in hell
crashing into theaters on May 22nd was
one of the two big films for Tom Cruise
in 1996 and that's Mission Impossible
it's a continuation of both the original
television series created in 1966 and
the revived sequel series that began in
1988 and it's set six years after the
events of the latter Tom Cruise stars as
Government operative Ethan Hunt who
recruits a small team to help him prove
his innocence after he becomes the prime
suspect in the murder of his mentor
Mission Impossible delivered one of the
most memorable scenes slash images of
90s action flicks when Tom Cruise drops
and hovers inches from the grounds
foreign
[Music]
as it turns out he put coins in his
shoes for balance and to keep his head
from hitting the floor remember that all
you future spies out there this marked
the first installment and what has
become quite the film series with a
seventh installment due in 2023 but this
is actually the only film in the
franchise where Ethan Hunt doesn't fire
a gun nor are there any shootouts or
gunfights at all critics say full of
special effects Brian De Palma's update
of Mission Impossible has a lot of
sweeping spectacle but the plot is
sometimes convoluted
[Music]
freeze mister
oh drop the gun
all right drop your boss escaping into
theaters on June 7 1996 was the
memorable action flick the rock directed
by action extraordinaire Michael Bay and
it wasn't about the rock Nicholas Cage
stars as an FBI chemical warfare expert
who teams up with a former British spy
played by Sean Connery to stop a nerve
gas attack launching from the old
Alcatraz prison and into San Francisco
much of the filming took place on
location at Alcatraz Island but since
it's run by the National Park Service it
couldn't close down and production had
to work around tour parties that were
walking through
gentlemen
smokes
[Music]
coming off this critically acclaimed
performance in Leaving Las Vegas the
year before cage was about to go on a
serious run of popular action movies and
it pretty much started with the rock
which went on to become the fourth
highest grossing movie of 1996. critics
say for visceral Thrills it can't be
beat just don't expect the rock to
engage your brain
[Music]
not
for the hills it's Godzilla
boy look like King Kong
[Music]
oh you look fabulous opening on June
28th was the Eddie Murphy comedy The
Nutty Professor a remake of the 1963
film of the same name Murphy plays a
morbidly obese University Professor who
comes up with a miraculous yet
experimental weight loss drug that also
brings out an evil Alter Ego The Nutty
Professor also features Jada Pinkett and
Dave Chappelle in supporting roles but
it's Murphy who shines playing seven
different roles in the film including
most of his character's family you want
your opponent Clan man I'm a clean man
yeah
of course he had a little help behind
the scenes from a team that won the
Oscar for best makeup and all it took
was keeping Eddie in the chair roughly
three hours a day to pull it off the
fresh film performed well at the box
office and spawned a sequel in 2000.
critics say The Nutty Professor falls
back on juvenile humor eagerly and often
but Eddie Murphy's consistently funny
work and dual roles means more for
audiences to love
[Music]
good luck buddy
oh boys
I'm back
this film starring Bill Pullman and Will
Smith is about a worldwide attack by an
extraterrestrial race and the different
groups of people who come together in
the Nevada desert to try and figure out
a way to fight back Roland Emerick
directed and co-wrote this film and
while Smith has some memorable moments
it's Bill Pullman's role as President
Whitmore that people still talk about I
like Lucas
they're moving from planet to planet
their whole civilization after they've
consumed every natural resource they
move on
and we're next the marketing campaign
for Independence Day began with the
Airing of a dramatic commercial during
Super Bowl 30 which cost a cool 1.3
million dollars but it's all good
because this became the highest grossing
film of 1996 and was nominated for two
Oscars for best sound and best visual
effects winning the latter critics say
the plot is thin and so is character
development but as a thrilling
spectacle-filled Summer movie
Independence Day delivers
Kali
I
I a friend we ain't no friends Jake
we on different sides of the line
I ain't never seen you in my part of
town I bet you don't even know where I
live
our daughter's Jake
they ain't never gonna play together and
what are you talking about
America
is a war
and you on the other side
coming at the end of July was the film A
Time to Kill based on John grissom's
1989 novel of the same name Samuel
Jackson stars is a heartbroken father
who avenges his daughter's brutal rape
by shooting the bigoted men responsible
and he looks to an untested lawyer
played by Matthew McConaughey for help
this marked the fourth film adaptation
of a John Grissom novel and after not
initially wanting to sell the rights to
this his first book he finally relented
for a record price of six million
dollars plus casting approval do you
think Carly's shooting you was
intentional
no sir
it was an accident
do you think he should be punished for
shooting you
no sir the fresh film was number one at
the box office its first couple of weeks
and pulled in a decent amount overall it
also earned Sam Jackson a Golden Globe
nom for best supporting actor and
Matthew McConaughey in an MTV movie
award for breakthrough performance
critics say over long and superficial A
Time to Kill nonetheless succeeds on the
strength of its skillful craftsmanship
and top-notch performances
I think I better tell you something hi I
hope I'm not late
[Music]
um hi
hi
um
this is my friend Renee
are you two gonna have a baby kicking
off a fresh TV season on August 26 1996
was the family drama series 7th Heaven
it centers around the lives of Reverend
Eric Camden and his family living in the
fictional town of Glen Oak California it
marked the first major role for Jessica
Beale who played daughter Mary Camden
for the show's First Seven Seasons
you've never kissed a guy oh by the time
girls in my class were kissing boys in
my class
uh I was taller than every guy in my
class the difference doesn't make tall
short who cares oh it's too weird
kissing a guy shorter than me I want to
kiss someone taller than me
who
there's no who oh yeah there is who is
he it doesn't matter seventh heaven
aired for 10 seasons on the WB becoming
the Network's longest running series
ever and then finished out its 11th
final season on the CW after the big
merger airing its 243rd and final
episode in May of 2007.
[Music]
we've got an illegal cable splitter on
your roof
you didn't know nothing about it right
oh and it's a real cheap one that's why
your cable service went out right I'm
surprised at you what did you do I
didn't do anything I don't even know
what a splinter is it splits your signal
and it sends it somewhere else and in
this case right across the street to
that house
also beginning a long series run in
September of 96 was the CBS sitcom
Everybody Loves Raymond which would run
until 2005 with a total of 210 episodes
over nine Seasons Ray Romano stars as a
successful sports writer who deals with
the daily ups and downs of having a
family of his own while his parents and
brother also live across the street
fish you know what I think I put it in
the fridge what
here it is
romano was one of many comedians who got
a shot at their own show at the time
especially after a five minute set on
Letterman in 95 with the success of Home
Improvement Seinfeld and Roseanne
setting the stage before him the result
was one of the most beloved sitcoms in
the history of Television winning 15
Emmys on 69 nominations and living on
for new audiences to enjoy in
syndication critics say there's plenty
to Love in This witty Riff on the push
and pull of family from Ray Romano's
self-deprecating comedy to the Sterling
roster of supporting players
you think just because I'm a movie star
I don't have feelings well you're wrong
I do have feelings I'm an actress I have
all of them well I wouldn't understand
you see I'm just a poor little housewife
and a little apron with a little child
to raise yeah well you were always
Justin even in college because I was
blonde and beautiful and talented and I
could have any guy I wanted and did
every guy most of the senior class and
half the faculty well it was the 60s
opening in theaters on September 20th
was the star-studded comedy First Wives
Club directed by Hugh Wilson and based
on Olivia Goldsmith's 1992 novel of the
same name this film stars Diane Keaton
Bette Midler and Goldie Hawn as three
divorces looking for payback against
their ex-husbands who left them for
younger women the film was considered a
surprise box office success after
grossing more than 181 million dollars
Lititz from Brenda's father about stuck
in your stores with stolen merchandise
so what do they call it in the tabloids
hot stuff
criminal activity you should be ashamed
wake up
and smell the audit and despite mixed
reviews and a rotten score on the Tomato
Meter it has since developed a cult
following mostly among middle-aged women
it also marks the three main actresses
highest grossing projects of the 90s and
as critics have argued help Breathe new
life into some of their careers critics
say First Wives Club is headlined by a
trio of comedic dynamos but the script
lets them down with tepid plotting and a
fatal lack of satirical bite
[Music]
I need a darling good morning gorilla
what a Charming dog and arriving in
droves over Thanksgiving weekend was
Disney's live action 101 Dalmatians
adapted from the 1961 animated film and
the 1956 novel of similar names along
with the roughly 300 puppies it took to
make this film Glenn Close stars as an
evil high-fashion designer who is out to
steal Dalmatian puppies in order to make
a fancy fur coat Sigourney Weaver was
offered the role of Cruella but turned
it down as did close initially but the
film's costume designer Anthony Powell
happened to be working with the latter
on the Broadway show Sunset Boulevard
and he convinced her to do it oh
did Anita tell you the news
she's going to have a baby
is this true
true oh you poor thing I'm so sorry the
film was a hit at the box office
becoming the sixth highest grossing film
of the year and closest performance was
praised despite poor overall reviews
from the critics she returned for a
sequel in 2000 102 Dalmatians which was
also not well received but did have one
more Dalmatian which is always a good
thing critics say need performance from
Glenn Close aside 101 Dalmatians is a
bland pointless remake
Jesus Christ you don't know the rules I
have an aneurysm why don't you there are
certain rules that one must abide by in
order to successfully survive a horror
movie for instance number one you can
never have sex
and finally ending 1996 with a loud
sharp piercing cry was the slasher film
scream directed by Wes Craven and
deliberately released five days before
Christmas to give moviegoers another
option besides family flicks the film's
ensemble cast is led by franchise
Mainstays Nev Campbell Courtney Cox and
David Arquette and it tells the story of
a small town with a mysterious Mass
killer on the loose Cox made her way to
scream while she was looking to offset
her quote nice character from friends
and skied alrich was cast after Joaquin
Phoenix reportedly turned down the role
of Billy while Matthew Lillard just
happened to be in the building for
something unrelated when he was asked to
audition for and landed the part of stew
thank you
together
at the end of Kevin Williamson's
screenplay for the film was a five-page
treatment for Scream 2 which turned into
a full-on script after scream became a
hit ultimately launching a legit
franchise that is still going strong a
couple of decades later critics say
horror icon Wes Craven's subversive
deconstruction of the genre is Sly witty
and surprisingly effective as a slasher
film itself even if it gets a little too
cheeky for some oh wow that was fun I
haven't hung out in the 90s in like
forever what was your favorite movie or
TV moment from 1996 don't answer right
now take your time and think about it
you could even go back and watch this
again if you really think that will help
I wonder what year we'll visit in the
next episode if you gotta tune in to
find out so until then take care of
yourselves